[Musique]
hier soir nous recevions en exclusivité
notre nouvelle miss france viennent
l'air l'occasion de faire connaissance
avec celle qui va porter durant un an la
couronne et de faire un petit débrief
sur la cérémonie de samedi soir je suis
très heureux de rencontrer miss france
2022 elle est magnifique vraiment sommes
notamment revenu sur une séquence qui a
beaucoup fait réagir les internautes
la coiffure de miss aquitaine vivement
critiqué le soir de l'élection nan mais
c'est horrible ce qu'ils ont fait aux
cheveux de miss aquitaine si sylvie
tellier qui accompagne et miss france
2002 a précisé que les candidates
étaient libres du choix de leur coiffure
il faut respecter aussi ses goûts après
tout on a droit de faire ce qu'on aime
avec ses chevaux gilles verdez a remis
en doute ces propos dénonçant une forme
de racisme banalisé en voulant lycée des
cheveux afro essais libres de leur image
est-elle vraiment libre une prise de
position que le chroniqueur affichent
systématiquement dès qu'il s'agit de
personnes de couleur et qui commence à
lasser certains téléspectateurs alors
accusé de racisme anti-blancs comprenez
vous les critiques contre gilles verdez
alors les cherry et c'est vrai que mon
gilles verdez est vectrice de tout ça je
pense à manger loin est-ce que déjà
parce qu'on comprenait oui oui oui oui
oui non j'ai d'abord commencé par un non
parce que non pas tout de suite mathieu
de langues ben oui franchement ça
devient gênant ça fait sept ans que fait
cette émission ça fait sept ans que
gilles systématiquement quand ce sera
une miss france de couleurs qui était
lui crie au racisme tu cries à la triche
ça devient très très très gênant le
racisme existe dans les deux sens ça me
faisait penser un jour âme à spike lee
kva réalisateur qui avait dit a pas
assez de blancs dans les films il est
fait jungle fever mais tant que des
noirs et bien toi tu fais la même chose
alors je comprends que tu adores fatou
je comprends que tu es une préférence
pour les femmes de couleur mais ça ne
fait pas des femmes blanches des femmes
qui sont différentes qui sont faits si
c'est comme ça si la
chaleur rapport on le voit gila vous
êtes un peu dur
c'est ce que je ressens gilles
systématiquement le reste et de raciste
années qu'ils veulent dire les deux sens
et s'il étudie vise les français alors
qu'elisabeth bonsoir
bonsoir elizabeth je comprends pas les
insultes les menaces réseaux etc donc je
voudrais dire déjà pour commencer assez
bien et j'ai une dent contre vous depuis
le jour où je vous ai entendu dire des
horreurs subies là et je suis contente
de pouvoir voulu dire parce que c'était
vraiment dégueulasse de pas défendre
cette jeune fille c'est à dire dont la
vie a été bouleversée alors c'est vrai
que j'ai un peu une dent contre vous
alors on a été plus rien avait plusieurs
qu'ils n'ont pas défendu
oui mais gilbert désamianter
particulièrement virulent je tiens à
dire aussi que j'étais d'accord avec
votre position sur les jo maintenant
d'accord quand louis je ne dirais pas
que vous êtes un raciste anti blanc je
dirais que vous ne le voyez pas c'est à
dire vous êtes hémiplégique pour vous le
racisme c'est toujours dans un sens il
n'ya que le dire les gens de la
diversité les arabes les noirs qui
peuvent être victimes de racines mais
jamais auteur est votre réaction face à
thaïs mab totalité des skiffs ont décidé
la semaine dernière me rappelais plus
son nom et ça m'a tout à fait sidéré si
vous voulez d'abord parce que vous dites
toute la journée qu'ils pouvaient
écouter les victimes et côté des
victimes avant même la moindre preuve il
faut les croire là comme par hasard vous
aviez pas l'air de tellement l'écouté et
puis dès qu'elle a commencé à expliquer
c'est à dire le et je crois que benjamin
castaldi aussi étaient dans ce cas c'est
à dire des cannes a dit que son
agresseur était tunisiens vous avez
hurlé c'est à dire en comme si c'était
vraiment horrible de dire ça or je crois
que très souvent ça arrive ya une
dimension culturelle c'est pas génétique
c'est tout simplement qu'ils aient un
choc de cultures c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui viennent de culture répressive qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir des femmes
libres et pour qu'ils annoncent vous
trouvez que c'est benjamin banon mais là
je peux d'accord et vous un autant so
close il parfois il va un peu trop loin
et je sais pour élever mais je sais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord mais franchement ce
sont des discussions on n'a pas remis en
cause son agression on a remis en cause
son discours post agression et où il
avait remis en cause le fait qu'elle
précise de son agresseur et des
tunisiens son discours post agression en
mettant en avant des chiffres que de 11
et mamadou wade sort bien mais en disant
voilà c'est en stigmatisant une fois
plus les arts et moi j'suis pas d'accord
avec ces pas les arabes ils'agit il
s'agit excusez moi le harcèlement et ben
je vous prends un exemple celle qui est
difficile à contester ces cologne et olé
est-ce que vous admettez quatre colonnes
y avait une dimension qui n'était pas
simplement des faits divers que c'est
des gens venus de cultures extrêmement
répressive qui confrontés à des femmes
libres et bien perdu leurs deux heures
et qu'aussi bien vrai que j'aimerais
qu'ils répondent quand même à ce que le
cours répond d'abord sur taille si vous
voulez rien pas mis d'accord alors thaïs
je n'ai absolument pas remis en cause le
drame qu'elle vivait le fait divers
bailleurs et une enquête judiciaire j'ai
dit que je trouvais que la juxtaposition
qu'elle faisait de ce drame avec la
récupération soient jugés comme une
récupération politique
avec des statistiques qu'elle avait
prévu ça m'a choqué ça m'a gêné j'ai
trouvé que le moment où l ai parlé avec
émotion de son drame était bouleversant
et d'un coup il ya un autre les sarthois
laissa à l'émotion de son âme oui
après il y avait une sorte de
récupération politique de discours
politiques et moi ma chaîne y avoir une
interprétation qui je dirais plutôt
culturel que politique j'ai pas trouvé
était à dire que peut-être ça n'était
pas complètement un hasard si vous
voulez et de fait vous voyez bien que
leur harcèlement par exemple il est
quand même un peu plus fréquent à la
chapelle que dans un certain nombre de
quartiers c'est un dollar à clermont
pour
sucrer sûr j'aimerais qu'on assure
gilles je vais tout pour cartes si vous
pouviez les garde jusqu'à la fin de la
séquence merci bernard tu vas tu
exprimes dans un instant je serai juste
d'abord avoir bien ok pas d'accord avec
tous nos maîtres l'équipe à d'ailleurs
c'est pas parce que gilles et c'est vrai
je reconnais il a tendance à voir du
racisme partout qu'il est lui-même
raciste gilles c'est quelqu'un de très
humain il défend les personnes qui sont
le plus victimes de racisme et c'est
vrai que c'est les personnes noires ou
d'origine maghrébine ça c'est une
réalité et c'est je pense qu'elles sont
nos québécois bas en france ces
modalités suis désolé dépendant
quelqu'un rythme s'est invitée dans
certains quartiers on vous fait traiter
de faces de craie c'est pas
la même personne question victimes non
et je pense qu'il le fait de manière un
peu excessive parce qu'il le fait avec
son coeur et ça c'est voilà c'est un
fait mais ça ne le rend pas raciste
peloton mais mon père ma santé j'ai
gardé ce n'est pas du tout à ça qui
m'énerve c'est qu'on a on est en train
de les gens qui les gens qui sont
ouvertement racistes vous les victimiser
odette son agression évidemment et les
gens qui combattent le racing voulait
traiter de raciste c'est d'abord les
gens moi je n'ai pas traité de raciste
pas si ou non gelée traité d'hémiplégie
qaîda bugs excusez-moi j'ai appartements
prévus en allant vers ces autres à
didier rey qu'il ne voyait pas le
racisme anti blanc qu'elle refusait
d'avoir des gens qui le tue cette
affaire de miss france excusez moi moi
je pense que c'est un appel il a jamais
dit que du racisme alors moi je vais
vous répondre je combats le racisme sous
toutes ses formes et de sensibilité je
condamne autant
la profanation du carré musulman à
mulhouse que l'attaqué contre une
procession catholique à nanterre mais ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le musulman air
france
stigmatisés et qui sont stigmatisés
parce qu'ils sont musulmans et moi je le
dis je sais que je suis minoritaire et
je le dis quand milla attaque beaucoup
la religion musulmane moi
personnellement j les eaux ne représente
que moi ça me gêne je trouve que la
religion chacun le droit de la ville
tranquillement paisiblement chez lui
couvert par les 10 au blasphème ne doit
excuser briller oui mais mes joues je
suis sincère le faites vous pas vous
parler votre coeur vous parlez je parle
dit ce que je ressens moins sur la leçon
à personne en vie je le dis et je sais
que cette position elle peut être
content et soulagé content et je le sais
mais moi ça me non mais ce que je veux
dire que c'est que moi ça me gêne quand
on attaque les religions parce que je
trouve que chacun doit pouvoir vivre
tranquillement en france je relis sa
religion donc j'ai trouvé que certaines
des attitudes ou des mots ou des
provocations de mila était pour moi
choquant et je les dis et je ne regrette
pas de l'avoir dès maintenant je
condamne tout aussi fermement que vous
les menaces c'est alan compris
évidemment j'allais vous dire est ce que
vraiment vous d'abord on a le droit de
critiquer les religions je le sais alors
non mais juste une chose c'est que
évidemment c'est assez je comprends
qu'on puisse ne pas entendre la nuance
entre critiquer une religion et dénoncer
les croyants mais ça n'est pas la même
chose chez navré mais ça n'est pas la
même chose en plus moi je considère et
vous n'êtes pas d'accord qu'il ya un
problème spécifique aujourd'hui
d'acculturation de l'islam mais ça c'est
faux je peux pas vous lasser les bêtises
on met d'accord mais on met ça veut dire
que ces pots excuses des marges en
innovant médias lui non
oui on non musulman où devait pour la
rentrée non vous devez pouvoir entendre
des choses avec lesquelles vous n'êtes
pas d'accord voilà je suis navré c'est
comme ça il ya une enquête qui a une
semaine qui nous disent 60% plus de 60 %
des lycéens musulmans ou des lycéens en
croyant musulman considère que l'islam
et au su de la république si vous ne
trouvez pas que c'est un problème si
vous pensez si vous voulez que tout ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui les je ne parle
même pas des attentats je parle
simplement de ce qu'on appelle le sépare
at il dû au fait que les juifs ont
quitté l'école publique antenne samedi
c'est pas pour rien si vous voulez et
bien il y a quand même beaucoup de gens
qui ne dit pas paisiblement le royaume à
19 jours il ya des musulmans
tranquillement leur nom il ya % qui
l'ont condamné après dany ces maisons
les toutes les études montrent le
contraire tous fait des études montrent
qu'il ya une grosse minorité de 30%
toutes les études le monde cnrs institut
montaigne la justice avait il avait six
mois le débat c'est parce que j'ai là tu
aurais vraiment c'est dans les embarquer
là dessus je lui aurais pas rien c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet on en reparlera
d'ailleurs jeudi soir d'accord avec avec
eric zemmour mais c'est vrai que la
sienne et ça n'est pas le sujet la ccl
plus gilbert daydé mois quand ce que dit
gilles verdez chez vous dire s'est
produite vers des et je connais un petit
peu et on entend tellement de choses
aujourd'hui de discours en direct à la
télévision
anti-musulmans qu' il ya beaucoup de
musulmans je vous le dis qu'ils qui
commence à vraiment à se replier sur eux
mêmes ils n'osent plus sortir ils
n'osent plus aller faire des sorties ils
sortent une chose plus parler et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
aussi que vraiment il ya une
stigmatisation sur les musulmans sur
différentes émissions sur différentes
antennes sur différents discours qu'on
peut entendre et on voit là la campagne
qui a démarré elle est extrêmement à
droite elle et c'est vrai qu'à pas un
candidat qui ne parle pas des musulmans
ou de l'islam donc vous comprenez bien
que les gens qui bat qui nous regardent
et les personnes qui arrivent à
télévision les personnes qui regardent
un meeting à un moment ils se disent on
a l'impression qu'on veut pas de nous
dans ce pays ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué pas de certaines banques ça
devient plus compliqué plus en plus
compliqué pour les musulmans aussi de
vivre en france je lis si c'est ce que
tu me dire je pense justement c'est ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ils se
sentent rejetés ça le pire moi j'en
connais beaucoup des allemands devraient
commencer à dire mais nous on est
rejetée alors que c'est très dur on est
très très dur français comme tous les
français on en doute un du nord mais
voilà oui c'est ça qu'on veut et pas
seulement des papiers la france s'est
aussi des moeurs une culture excusez moi
par exemple quand vous allez un grand
musée moi mais quand vous avez d'autres
appels dans les morts ce ne peut pas
aller dans certaines banlieues habillés
comme des bureaux à londres
eh ben vous voulez vous habiller comme
vous voulez mais l avis de m et et
gilles verdez en mini jupe c'est d'avoir
tous les deux jouent moins bonne foi
mais ce qui me terrifie c'est que vous
ne voyez pas vous ne voyez pas ce qui
saute aux yeux vous croyez quoi que les
français sont devenus tout d'un coup
c'est à dire ils sont dit vraiment on
sait qu'il ya pas de problème avec
l'islam dur mais il ya eu énormément des
nourrissons mais ses frères musulmans de
l'islam qui est un problème mais c'est
il ya énormément discours kiwi kiki
c'est l'islam politique en fait j'avais
à bernard montiel sur gilles verdez non
moi je dis je vais dire tout de suite
parce que d'abord je suis bienveillant
et je vais direct il n'est pas raciste
notre ami le seul problème qu'il a c'est
que l'amour rend aveugle et qui manque
de discernement donc à chaque fois on
retombe sur les même thèse avec lui donc
du coup il est inaudible c'est vrai ça
devient difficile en revanche elisabeth
ya un truc qui me choque chez vous c'est
quand vous dites les cultures agressive
ça c'est violent je trouve ça me choque
de dire ça aille a dit me l'avait dit
trois fois j'ai pas dit le mot agressive
je crois non si les cultures agressive
non espagne alors excusez moi non non
franchement vous avez mal an autour du
palais alors que vous avez simplement
dit que la france est un pays qui
demandent un peu plus que les autres
peut-être on s'adapte effectivement à
rome fais comme les romains avant on
appelait ça la simulation moi quand je
vais à epinay sur seine ou à saint denis
et cetera que je vois des gens qui
vivent selon simplement les moeurs
islamique c'est à dire que vous n'avez
plus que je suis désolé merci cela il ya
maintenant mais arrêtez pourquoi les
gens sont partis d'eux c'est beaucoup
mieux est ce que ça vous est ce que ça
vous inquiète
cela est ce que vous n'avez de la
compassion pour les gens pour les juifs
qui ont quitté ses bras mais est-ce que
cela vous vous demandez pourquoi la
compassion pour tout le monde mais c'est
un autre débat se plaît à dieu que c'est
le même chemin qu un simple et on essaie
d'arrêter de arrêté deux interpellés
jamais ah oui alors mathieu ben moi je
dis ce que je pense et agit d ce que je
trouve un peu dommage c'est qu'il
s'exprime pas très bien je trouve qu'ils
divisent freeman non mais gardons je
trouve que tu divises beaucoup parce que
tu es très clivant systématiquement et
parce que je trouve que souvent je pense
que le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est c'est qu'on y des choses qui
existent plutôt que de trouver des
solutions par exemple quand organes
enquête exclusive en disant c'est faux
ce qui se passe en banlieue c'est faux
là forcément tu insultes les gens qui
sont là bas et pour qui c'est vrai je
pense que le vrai discours ça serait
dire voilà c'est vrai ce qui se passe
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
tant que ça se passe plus et toi
systèmatiquement tués dans le déni de ça
et c'est ça qui fait qu'il ya un moment
donné on ne comprend plus ton discours
parce que non il ya des choses qui se
passe dehors gilles et maintenant la
vrai que le vrai discours c'est de dire
comment faire en sorte que ça ne se
passe pas c'est ça la chose alors et
géraldine alors d'abord les menaces et
les insultes c'est insupportable mais on
en a tous subi non mais on a tout subi
parce qu'à partir du moment où comme
gilles sa force c'est d'avoir des avis
tranchés et des positions très clivante
c'est aussi sa fragilité et c'est aussi
sa faiblesse alors après moi ce qui me
gêne avec tous âges il sait que souvent
tu essentialise d'ailleurs c'est comme
s'il y avait un racisme systémique en
france comme si tu es presque à un
système organisé par l'état comme si tu
considérais pas que l'actu la police est
raciste que quelques quelques policiers
sont racistes et ça moi je trouve que ça
c'est troublant parce qu'en fait je
trouve que c'est contreproductif c'est à
dire que sous des apparences
d'antiracisme en fait tu te positionnes
d'une certaine d'une certaine manière
dans un autre racisme qui est tout aussi
ravageur et j'ai l'impression malgré
tout que dès que tu parlais dès que tu
prends la parole en fait tu fait le jeu
des extrêmes oui tu fais le jeu de
l'extrême droite est en fait ils se
régalent les gens parce qu'en fait tu
tombe tellement dans pas notre cuisine
est en fait un super g c'est comme si tu
insultes et le blanc qui dit moi je suis
pas raciste mais moi je m'en fous eo2 de
quoi il parle en fait pourquoi on me
fait passer pour un radar en fait ça
hystérise le truc et je pense que ça
nous sépare plutôt que ça nous ça nous
désole m il faut s'en tenir aux détails
tout con gilles à propos du concours
miss france parce que c'est parti de là
j'allais revenir la jeune femme elle se
coiffe comme elle veut et toi tu lis à
droite en israël est tellement mieux
avec quelle coiffure africaine pour
parce qu'elle s'est passé comme ça on
est obligées oui mais pas du tournage et
au téléphone la rue et par les amis
s'acquitter à l'enlever parlait
justement et voilà ce qu'elle m'a dit
texto elle m'a dit c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'elle voulait parce que j'aurais aimé
plus affreux et j'aimerais que comme
dans d'autres pays étrangers où une
coiffe la couronne sur une coiffure a
trop j'aimerais que le règlement de miss
france évolue et qu'on puisse être
coiffé afro donc voilà elle ne dit pas
qu'on l'a obligé mais elle dit qu'elle
n'a pas pu réaliser à l'afro el maali
tous les jours j'ai ma coiffure afro
tous les jours je fais comme ça donc là
je suis désolé je ne dis pas que là je
ne dise sûrement pas que la police ait
rassis je défends les policiers je ne
dis pas que miss france et rassis je
défends miss france mais elle dit que
parfois c'est pas mal de dénoncer quand
il ya des choses qui ne vont dans les
salles à lyon saint laurent mais mon
modeste niveau ce que je veux bien nommé
semble hélas je vous ai mal compris il
m'a semblé goodies etc en fait quand
c'était je ne sais plus laquelle demi ce
qu'avait été élu et que ça elle n'avait
été justement s'est arrêtée blanc je
vous avais dit cette phrase 1016 il vaut
mieux une belle queue blanc à 2016 qui
vont mieux et blanche de belles excusez
moi ça c'est vraiment quand voir du
racisme là où il n'existe pas c'est ce
que je pensais à voile à corne et
travailler encore absolument encore une
fois je vous avez raison je le répète
moi je vous avais tort de dire oui on en
subit tout de ma peut-être pas si la
vidéo est ce qu'on a mais c'est mal
qu'une miss c'est donc ce n était pas l
ai dit aussi qu'un grand joueur de
football sénégalais qui s'appelle sadio
manet qui avait pas eu le ballon d'or
2010 9 il avait perdu plein de voix
parce qu'il était noir vous je les dis
on va
vous répondre sur une chose parce que je
vous excusez moi ont foutu je suis nul
mais je me rappelle vous a entendu
parler de benzema oui et vous avez dit
que c'est par racisme que benzema
n'avait pas été choisi c'est aussi je me
trompe je me suis dit que ça entrer en
ligne de compte un moment musulmans lors
du benzema était en pleine affaire mais
franchement crapuleuses c'est-à-dire ça
aurait été n'importe qui d'autre vous
auriez se remettra tout à fait normal et
pas ce que fait il a les mains c'était
du racine dit on encore je le revends
donc débouler quelque chose un noir ou
un arabe c'est du racisme mais n'en
revendique quelque chose s est
effectivement tu armée des meilleures
intentions mais parfois justement
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions et
comme tu essentialiste où tout est un
problème lié ce forcément à la personne
alors si elle est noire c'est parce que
elle est noire si elle est juive c'est
parce qu'elle est juive si elle est
arabe c'est parce qu'elle est arabe à
chaque fois en fait tu ni l'identité
intrinsèque même en disant on est des
citoyens français et donc à chaque fois
comme tu es idéologiquement marquée du a
très envie que ça que ça rentre dans ta
grille de lecture en fait c'est pour ça
que chaque année quand on quand on
revient du lendemain de miss france nous
on se dit tous en rigolant tient 7,7
cette année encore gilles va trouver
qu'il ya du racisme parce que ça en
devient presque a pas que moi qui le
dira non mais tu insultes et tous les
gens qui n'a pas tendu là tu te dis oui
ou non non moi je pense que moi j'ai mis
oui j'ai mis oui au delà de ça je pense
que gilles est tellement sensible est
tellement extrême dans toutes ses
opinions qui veut bien faire il veut
vraiment bien faire et moi je pense que
sa cause est noble sincèrement mais je
pense qu'il le fait maladroitement et je
ne pense pas qu est-ce que des impôts ni
âmes est en fait je ne pense pas que ça
fait
de désaccords le désaccord fait partie
quand même de notre culture commune je
pense donc je pourrais vous le
reconnaître comment bien sûr mais enfin
bon jouer sans sa cousine à
chaque fois
vous dire puisque vous vous arrêtez pas
de dire que rho stigmatiser mais de
musulmans avec la terreur vous dire moi
je prends mes compatriotes musulmans
pour des adultes d'accord oui oui est-ce
que je crois par exemple c'est qu'ils
peuvent tout à fait entendre que le
droit au blasphème dans notre pays est
un droit que ça leur plaise ou pas mais
nous sommes tous amenés à écouter des
opinions qui nous déplaisent et le poiré
bien plus que les autres plus que jamais
il faut arrêter de crier au racisme
parce aux critiques quelque chose on s'y
rend et si on appelle l obs que les
autres bah oui
quand tu dis pas dans l'équipe
la mire les musulmans aussi en apaisant
question projet et demi gilles quand il
ya une miss france qui est lui qui est
noir alors que tu ne sais quoi alors que
ça formidable
les enjeux ça veut dire qu'on est
raciste l'année pour
moi explique yann deux secondes et oui
mais vous ne me ferez pas changé là
dessus mais qui ont réussi leur année de
sonia rolland langer s'est tenue juste
d'apprendre les zones ira sanaka
fréquence et clémence matinaux on n'est
pas là dessus c'est plus difficile quand
on est noir d'être élue miss france que
quand on est belle oui je ne changerais
par là dessus
qu'est ce qui vous permet
même franchement qu'est ce qui vous
permet de dire sans accuser dracénois
comprenez vous du crédit contre gilles
verdez oui à 63% à ces bêtes qui
dénoncent ils ghassan ben là 37 cents
m